hey youtubers is Charlie so there's a
bunch of stuff that's been happening
around the Gotham TV show that's going
to air this fall so I wanted to do a
breakdown of all the new villains as
well some of the things that people are
saying about the pilot they actually
screen the first episode for a bunch of
critics and they basically said that if
you're a Batman fan you're gonna love
this show which I think is really
exciting there was really only one
common complaint that people had but
I'll explain that as well as do a
breakdown of all the villains if you're
just finding me for the first time I do
DC and Marvel videos every week be sure
to subscribe to get everything
there's a lot of fun stuff happening
this summer especially since Comic Con
is coming up and I also pick a lot of
bonus topics based on the things that
you guys suggest so feel free to leave
me suggestions if there's something that
you guys really want to learn about so
important stuff first that pilot episode
just like Studios do for all big new
series they want to hype it I haven't
seen a lot of hype which i think is a
good thing the only thing the people who
have seen it are nervous about is the
number of stories threads that it sets
up the episode and the story is designed
specifically with the Batman fandom in
mind they're basically trying to set up
the entire season as well as the entire
series in that one episode so there is a
lot of stuff packed in but it means a
number of really awesome things first
they pay homage to all the characters
origins in really good ways I think this
is the most important part of the
equation if you look at a show like
arrow which has a slightly smaller main
cast the more time you spend developing
characters in the early episodes the
more pays off at the end of the season
Jim Gordon is the anchor of the show
it's told from his perspective Bruce
Wayne and all the other Batman
characters are just living in that world
previously the most we've seen of
Gordon's origins were in Batman year one
whenever Gordon was still a rookie cop
Gotham is playing with the origin
timeline just a little to make Ben
Mackenzie's version of the character a
new detective just as Thomas and Martha
Wayne are murdered it's like the oh [ __ ]
this is what I get on my first night on
the job kind of thing in Batman year one
Gordon was joining the Gotham City PD as
a rookie just as Bruce Wayne was taking
the mantle of a bat so in the comics as
well as the animated version of the
story it was like they were both new to
the game at the same time so the other
big thing that's being said about that
first episode is the idea of unfulfilled
promises in all these big stories
they're setting up I don't necessarily
think that that's a warning sign or a
bad thing but here's where we are with
it there's been McKenzie's Gordon they
have to establish his main story joining
the Gotham City PD and dealing with the
murder of Thomas and Martha Wayne
then there's the deck of cards that all
the other big characters comprise and a
few characters that we haven't seen yet
or we won't see but get referenced
inside the Gotham City PD there's Donal
Logue Bullock Christopher Nolan's Dark
Knight rollers you didn't really deal
with the character in great detail but
if you re watch Batman the animated
series you'll get a good feel for the
character expect this version of the
bullet character to be a little more
complicated because scoring an actor
like Logue is a bit of a win for the
series so whenever they cast big actors
like Donal Logue those people typically
bring something of their own to the
character most of you have probably seen
him on Vikings as King horik but if you
want to see what he might be like on
Gotham watch his episodes of Sons of
Anarchy
he plays a u.s. marshal that's forced to
retire because he gets too hardcore with
criminals the bullet character in the
Batman universe is all about
questionable methods and excessive force
he's something of a bully but he's not
an outright villain not in the way that
penguin or poison ivy our villains
Gordon is the cop is trying to be Zen
Bullock is the extreme as for villains
yes Jada pinkett-smith is the big bad of
the pilot they're going to go with a no
mutant no super villain policy in the
beginning it took arrow a long time to
get to super villains and the flash so
be patient NBC is doing Constantine
around the same time Gotham is going to
premiere this fall so there will be
full-on superpowers happening on
television just not on Gotham it's more
of like a dark gritty cop drama with
superheroes passing through it whenever
I first heard that Jada pinkett-smith
was going to be fish Mooney I actually
thought it was a reference to the
episode of the animated series called
The Laughing fish in that episode Joker
uses his laughing toxin on the fish
population in order to patent them and
make a bunch of money as in fish money
so I don't think that fish Mooney is a
direct reference to that but it might be
a funny Easter egg her character on the
show is more of a mob boss in the
Christopher Nolan Batman Begins
tradition it took Batman and Gordon
taking down organized crime in that
trilogy before the real supervillains
appeared I don't know how long they plan
to keep Jada Pinkett Smith's character
around but until she's out don't expect
any of the major super villains to
manifest powers as for all the known
super villains that are already cast on
the show they're going to be like proto
state it's a prequel series so they're
gonna get their prequel stories
to the penguin Oswald Cobblepot is a
mid-level thug played by Robin Taylor he
has one of the standout performances in
the pilot episode so I'm really excited
to see it just from looking at him you
can see they decided not to go with the
Tim Burton or comic-book versions of the
character that's just a network TV thing
everyone doesn't have to be a supermodel
but they want us to sympathize with the
character and it's a little harder to do
that when he appears much more comic
book II I will say i love the Danny
DeVito and animated versions of the
character but those were very different
universes this show is much more about
realism just like arrow in season 1 Joss
Whedon actually said this really
interesting thing about all these new
post superhero stories that are going on
like Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy he argued that he's not quite
ready to be done with the comic book II
aspects like the big Hulk's and the Iron
Man and the ridiculous plots but it's
easier to sustain a comic book show on a
television budget whenever you dial down
to special effects which is part of the
reason agents of shield was renewed for
season 2 it's not half as expensive as
it could have been had they done
Avengers level effects every week so the
other really big characters that we meet
in the pilot are the Riddler Edward
nygma he's working as a corner with the
police department and the poison ivy
character but her name isn't Pamela
Isley they changed it just a little bit
on the show her name is ivy pepper it
isn't fully explained why they did that
but for all intents and purposes she's
proto poison ivy and thus far they have
teased the Joker as well as Victor fries
although the Joker a little more overtly
remember Fox paid a dumptruck of money
to use the Batman characters but because
it's Fox don't expect any integration
with the Batman vs. Superman movie or
any of the other Justice League movies
that are happening in the next couple of
years
there also won't be any crossover with
arrow which I know is a bummer but it's
a completely different studio usually
what happens and what arrow has done
really well is reference things in the
DC Universe using like street names or
like that channel 52 news they
eventually did STAR Labs and now are
full-on flash so if Gotham plays its
cards right we'll totally get to see
those other Batman characters eventually
because the Batman universe is so much
bigger you know there's just so many
more comics and characters I think we're
gonna get all the non mutants first or
characters before they became mutants
like Killer Croc and mud face think
about how expensive mud face special
effects would be every week that'd be
crazy but the pilot is making me really
excited
a lot of the promises that it makes
won't really be paid off to like the
back half
the season like episode 9 10 11 so
whenever it airs in the fall be sure to
check it out it's going to be a lot of
fun I will be doing bonus videos all
summer so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
also let me know which next Batman
character you want to see come on the
show I'm really pulling for Victor
freeze I want to see him be the next one
so right now click here to get my
breakdown of the Gotham trailer and
click here to learn about the story in
Avengers 2 thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives